[Musik]
[Applaus]
das wasser ist etwas kalt aber es geht
leider hat es überall leute das ist
ärgerlich
nichts kannst du machen immer mal wieder
kommt jemand und schaut zu oder läuft
vorbei
[Musik]
seit 13 jahren lebt peter haimerl unter
dieser brücke die nächsten zwölf monate
werden ihn begleiten
wie lebt und überlebt dieser mann in
seiner selbst gewählten einsamkeit davon
handelt dieser film
wenn ich hier solide ist für mich die
welt zu ende heute habe ich wieder
komplett versagt aber jetzt muss ich
nichts mehr korrigieren wollen jetzt
kommt die nach die frühere nicht mehr
geht es gut alles ist okay
[Musik]
weihnachten 2015 ein milder nicht kalter
winter
der lärm ist ohrenbetäubend oben auf der
brücke bahnt sich das verkehrschaos
seinen weg durch zürich
unter der brücke hat alles seine ordnung
die kochnische mit feuerstelle pet
flaschen mit trink- und waschwasser
ein holzdieb ob alles sorgsam gehackt
und gestapelt
im laufe der jahre hat peter hammer wird
sich hier unten gut eingerichtet
[Musik]
man kann auch sagen dass ich hier wohne
aber das stört mich eigentlich
ich werde das nicht gerne fakt ist durch
wohne hier aber das ist nicht erlaubt
die kathi polizei war auch schon er ja
viele polizisten war und schon hier man
toleriert mich zwar hier aber in der
schweiz ist ja alles verboten oder
mindestens gesetzlich geregelt
mein turnier ist im grunde genommen so
genannt wildes campieren
hallo guten morgen und
vielen dank
jeden morgen bringt der fahrer eines
nili express etwas zu essen
sozialhilfe bezieht der 65 jährige peter
nicht sagt er
der gelernte dekorateur lebt von dem was
er findet oder was sind die leute vorbei
bringen meistens lebensmittel manchmal
auch geld hier geht's erken man muss es
gut aufbewahren
ich werde die regelrecht verwöhnt
das mag ich
es gibt hier leute die mich unterstützen
das sind aber immer etwa die gleiche
nahrungsmittel und wenn ich dann
zusätzlich nichts anderes esse wird es
eintönig
aber es ist wunderschön
keine familientragödie keine sucht keine
schulden peter hämmerle ist einfach ein
aussteiger vor 24 jahren beschloss er
den rest seines lebens allein zu sein
auch die jahreszeiten bestimmen wir mit
der einsamkeit zurechtkommt ich bin ein
morgenmuffel aber eben nicht immer
manchmal bin ich auch gut gelaunt und
voller tatendrang aber
jetzt in der weihnachtszeit und dann
noch das fehlende licht
das ist bedrückend ich habe ja kein
licht und dann muss ich bis zu 14
stunden im schlafsack liegen das ist
anstrengend
dabei habe ich nach sieben acht stunden
genügend schlaf gehabt und beim
rumliegen werde ich unruhig das so ein
scheiß ist das
eine meiner leibspeisen
nudeln mit knoblauch zwiebel mag ich
auch sehr aber die sind
ja dieses gericht mit knoblauch liebe
ich
[Musik]
zum ende des winters sind peter hämmerle
in zürich unterwegs
seine wenigen habseligkeiten wie
kleidung und den schlafsack nimmt damit
immer
peter rauch nicht alkohol konsumiert er
wenig
während des gesamten jahres sehen wir
ihn nur dieses eine mal etwas trinken
nicht schlecht aber ich habe nichts
gegessen
eigentlich würde ich den nun einsammeln
aber ich lass es bleiben
ich würde ihn mitnehmen nicht trinken
aber in eine kleine flasche umfüllen
aber dazu habe ich jetzt keine lust er
ist einwandfrei nicht verdorben
peter kennt seine stadt und weiß wo wann
was entsorgt wird ob sich das leicht
auseinandernehmen lässt das holz dient
als baumaterial
an die neugierigen blicke hatte sich
nach so langer zeit auf der straße
gewöhnt
angesprochen wird eher selten
je mehr tage wir mit ihm verbringen
desto mehr gibt peter hämmerle preis wir
erfahren von einem obdachlosen einem
tschechen der sich unter der brücke an
peters eigentum vergreift bis zum
schluss der dreharbeiten werden wir dem
unbekannten jedoch nicht begegnen
es ist fürchterlich mühsam mit diesem
elenden so verdammt mühsam das sind
meine kleider die trage ich an meinem
körper aber der typ macht einfach löcher
rein
nach mein gott sie hatte auch löcher
gemacht verfluchter misst
der typ ist raffiniert der hat
spezialgeräte um den stoff aufzubauen
wenn er die fäden durchschneidet
merkliches unverzüglich auch wenn er
löcher in die socken macht dann sehe ich
sofort dass das absicht ist
er laut den stoff irgendwie auf das
merke ich dann aber nicht gleich
zürich hier ist peter hämmerle
aufgewachsen
fotos und briefe aus seiner
vergangenheit gibt es keine mehr
im laufe der jahre auf der straße ging
alles verloren
das bauernhaus da drüben solche gibt es
noch einige hier in diesem stadtteil von
zürich in diesem bauernhaus im obersten
stock habe ich meine kindheit verbracht
dort wo die grüne hecke ist war eine
riesige scheune
eine behütete kindheit einfache
verhältnisse wenn auch mit strengen
eltern
mein vater war irgendwie ich weiß nicht
recht was einem stalker ist aber mein
vater war meiner meinung nach einer
die hat natürlich gefühle gezeigt aber
hat er sie nie lachen konnte er zwar
aber hauptsächlich war er die
ausführende gewalt die exekutive wenn
über mich gerichtet wurde weil ich
angeblich ein verzogener junge war der
unfug getrieben hat dann bin ich zur
guillotine geführt worden auf seine
oberschenkel und mir wurde der hintern
versohlt
mein vater ist verstorben wo meine
mutter ist weiß ich nicht ich glaube
aber nicht dass sie auch tot ist ich
habe keine beziehung mehr zu meiner
mutter wie vermutet sie lebt in einem
heim
peter haimerl hadert mit seiner
vergangenheit auch weil in zürich der
1950 er jahre kein platz war für
jugendliche die sich anders fühlten
das ist ein heikles thema
das milieu das damals geherrscht hat
man hat sich beispielsweise über
homosexualität lustig gemacht
auch auf dem schulhof unter den jungs
homosexualität war verpönt
in meiner kindheit und jugend hat man
homosexualität nicht als legal oder
normal betrachtet
[Musik]
es ist sommer sie haben peter harry
einige monate nicht gesehen wir treffen
ihn bei der limmat an seinem waschplatz
doch dieser drehtag wird für uns anders
verlaufen als gedacht
dort verflucht ihr mit eurem blöden
getue ihr arschlöcher
ich mag euch nicht ich mag diese welt
nicht dir zu bieten habt
und schaue doch noch dümmer du arschloch
dieses psychologische tour
was was ist das problem denn jetzt peter
wir wollten heute gemeinsam viel haut
endlich abflug nochmals ich will euch
nicht ihr verfluchten schleicher und
dieser verfluchte so und auch nicht der
mir alles zerschneidet
zwei stunden später peter hat sich
beruhigt sein emotionaler ausbruch ist
uns ein rätsel sprechen darüber wieder
nicht aber er ist bereit sich weiter von
uns und der kamera begleiten zu lassen
unter seine brücke dürfen wir nicht vor
dem zaun ist vorerst schluss
hierauf diese könnt ihr euch setzen
vielleicht noch eine zeitung als
unterlage
könnt ihr noch mehr machen
super danke dir also wir warten auf dich
ja
[Musik]
wir halten uns einstweilen zurück lassen
ihn in ruhe
zu beobachten
keine frage
[Musik]
peter scheint wieder versöhnt mit uns
erfahren den grund für seinen ausbruch
er wurde letzte nacht von dem
obdachlosen tschechien drangsaliert
wenn dieser kernig weiterhin sowie sagt
dann bin ich gezwungen für den nächsten
winter einen neuen schlafsack zu kaufen
der kostet sicher 300 franken
einer der gut genug ist für mich kostet
sicher so viel
[Musik]
ich gebe ein ice house für den frust von
heute morgen
ich nehme ein großes
[Musik]
möchten
zu nahe kommen und wir haben wir jetzt
gemerkt wenn wir zu nah sind dann muss
nicht so wie man aus und dann ist glaube
ich danach wieder gut ist schon gut
[Musik]
einige tage später
es ist fünf uhr an einem sonntagmorgen
unter der brücke
peter trifft letzte vorbereitungen für
sein wochenend ritual
bereit jetzt geht es los
die mütze setzte spät auf
eigentlich ist es für sein vorhaben
längst zu spät essen suchen proviant
aufstocken an der langstrasse es bereits
dran wer sich darin ist tag ich müsste
ein halb sechs herein
das hieße aber um halb vier auf stein
das problem sind die reinigungskräfte
der stadt durch um die straßen sauber
gibt es nichts mehr zu holen
es bereits durch einmal sind hier dinge
herumgelegen unglaublich die straße war
total zugemüllt er ist dran mit reinigen
küche ihn weiter vorne ich bin zu spät
[Musik]
bei der essence suche ist peter hämmerle
wählerisch
angebissen ist kein problem wenn es im
mülleimer gefunden wird auch nicht aber
sauber muss es sein er will nicht krank
werden
du bist ein filmstar oder was
ich verstehe dich nicht
französisch
französisch geht besser
ich habe heute lange gebraucht um etwas
zu essen zu finden
daran habe ich freude denn schwarze
männer gefallen mir männer interessieren
nicht mehr als frauen aber einfach zum
reden das habe ich gerne
polizisten sind ja auch immer zu zweit
auf streife und wir fehlt eine aber gut
einen polizisten duo liebt sich nicht
aber ich hätte gerne eine bezugsperson
das können liebe einschließen oder nicht
je nachdem
ich hätte gerne mit diesem mann noch
etwas länger gesprochen geübt
ja nun ist es bereits vorüber
das ist der anfang herbst
peter fühlt sich weiter von dem
obdachlosen tschechien schikanierten
will uns alternative schlafplätze zeigen
es wäre möglich hier oder auch dort
vorne zu schlafen darüber habe ich schon
nachgedacht aber
es gibt hier in der nähe viele
nachtclubs und dann herrscht nachts
betrieb hier hinten hinter diesen
dingern ist es offen es ist wohl das
heißt ich könnte ganz viele sachen darin
unterbringen
und man kann gut von hinten rein
aber wahrscheinlich kontrollieren die
von der bahn die kommen ja dauernd wegen
decken rechen kontrollen und dann
herrscht wieder betrieb
und es hat drogensüchtige mit denen will
ich nichts zu tun haben wir liegen auch
spritzen rum
[Musik]
selbst unter den randständigen der stadt
ist peter hämmerle außenseiter von der
obdachlosenszene in zürich grenzt er
sich ab
[Musik]
und nicht jeder der sich als obdachlose
ausgibt ist in seinen augen auch einer
den kann man gleich ins theater schicken
das ist kein richtiger obdachloser der
es viel zu perfekt viel zu schön
gestaltet kein richtiger
am rand von zürich unter den autobahn zu
bringen der stadt was
uns um gastlich und karg vorkommt das
scheint für einen menschen der im freien
lebt ein mögliches dach über dem kopf
mit einschränkungen
[Musik]
hier aber da muss ich irgendwo bretter
verstecken es ist zu mühsam die steine
weg zu räumen und jeden morgen wieder
hinzulegen
mit ein paar bauplatten und dann hat es
noch den gully dort hinten das könnte
gehen aber dann stellen sie mir meine
sachen
das ist ein spazierweg durch viertel
wahrscheinlich kommen hier in der nacht
jugendliche vorbei
hier könnte ich
die steine sind lässt sich sonst wäre es
wunderbar
[Musik]
das wäre auch ein platz der sich gut
eignet hier das laub
ich bin überzeugt wir haben schon
menschen geschlafen
hier ist es nachts total verlassen da
kommt keiner vorbei
schon an den plätzen die die angeschaut
haben ist das der beste
hier gibt's wasser man kann sich den po
waschen es gibt böse damit einen niemand
sieht dabei
das ist wirklich fast ein idealer ort
für mich als älterer mensch ist er auch
gut begehbar ich muss nicht über zäune
klettern oder irgendwohin aufsteigen
betreuten wg projekt leben
die vorstellung dieses leben aufzugeben
das bleibt eine fantasie es ist absurd
ich muss diesen weg gehen anders kann
ich nicht
wie ein anderes leben vorstellen
das erscheint wie real
es bleibt ein traum und ich lebe dieses
leben hier weiter
ich würde es nicht lange in so einem
betreuten wg projekt aushalten
nach drei vier wochen bin ich es leid
das weiß ich jetzt schon drei vier
wochen und ich bin wieder weg draußen
ramadan habe ich nichts mehr weit dass
hier wäre er dann weg ich habe keine
ahnung wie ich jemals von dieser art zu
leben wegkommen
der winkel 2016 ist hart
minustemperaturen
eisige kälte
[Musik]
so haben wir ihn noch nie gesehen die
jahreszeit macht dem eigentlich hart
gewordenen mann schwer zu schaffen
ein mist aber
ich kann ja nicht 24 stunden im
schlafsack liegen verflucht
[Musik]
ich kann nicht mehr verflucht ich friere
erbärmlich
vor genau einem jahr sind wir peter
hämmerle zum ersten mal begegnet jetzt
verabschieden wir uns von einem menschen
der die einsamkeit sucht sie
gleichzeitig verflucht aber sein leben
tag für tag tapfer meistert er hat uns
beeindruckt peter hämmerle der mann
unter der brücke
[Musik]
[Applaus]